we are on Episode one of feedback
Fridays and this week we are gonna be
talking about style scapes so I'm pretty
excited to look over your guys's works
for the ones that you guys have
submitted so far and if you aren't yet
go ahead and connect with us I'm at
Matthew and seen on all social platforms
as well as the future is here so connect
with us let's be friends on lines so
because this is the first episode you
guys might be wondering what is free
laughs sorry feedback Fridays sounds the
same feedback Fridays is just a way for
us to give you guys more feedback more
critiques because for those of you who
have been taken a course from us one of
the pieces of feedback that we got from
you guys is that you'd like more
opportunities to get your work reviewed
so that you can get better you know what
we look for what other people look for
and you know how to improve your design
work so you might be asking well how do
I get my stuff reviewed well if you're
part of our course you could sign up
here at Academy doubt the future comm we
have a private slack channel for alumni
alumni who've taken the course and we
send out messages there when we're
looking for submissions for this
critique session so let's get into it
you guys might be wondering what our
style escapes for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with style escapes style
escapes are a visual communication tool
so I put a written out version here but
essentially it's just a way to visualize
your ideas quickly so that you can share
them with your clients and you can have
a point of discussion because we know
that words are limited and sometimes you
need to respond to images colors
textures fonts you need to see these
things in order to have a robust and
productive conversation with your
clients so style escapes are our way of
bridging the gap between your strategy
the Design Thinking to a visual
direction something that you can see and
respond to if you guys have been
watching the building a brand series on
our other channel you guys saw that we
created this tile scape above which we
went through a couple of iterations and
rounds with the hamiltonfamily brewery
and eventually this became the brand
for everything that we created for them
from their cans and packaging to their
logos coasters March their website and
you can see that here with how these
things quickly translate from something
that is a bunch of curated reference
that we've tweaked and curated and
refined and turn this into brand applied
elements that you see below if you guys
haven't seen it yet go head over to
building a brand show comm because all
the episodes are on there as well as
episode breakdowns with more ways to
learn about our process and our whole
engagement with hamiltonfamily brewery
so let's get into these style scapes
critique I just wanted to check with my
team here do they say audios good
everything's alright before we move
forward all good fantastic let's get
into the critique so I'm gonna be
looking at a couple of your guys's style
scapes here and here is my criteria of
what I'm looking for
the first thing is does it communicate
clearly does it take the strategy the
the thoughts of where you guys are
coming from what your goals and
objectives are and does it communicate
that clearly for the brand attributes
that you've selected do those things
appear on page in a way that I can
understand second is it cohesive with
all the elements on do they feel like
they belong together did you do the
right amount of work a little bit of
color correction and tweaks to make all
the elements because they come from
different places I'll feel like they
belong together
and then the last one is do I know what
to make from this because style escapes
is not an end-all style escapes are just
a bunch of references it's just a
communication tool it is not the design
so one thing I wanted to clarify here is
that you use this as a starting point as
a point of discussion to build
everything from you don't use anything
from the style escapes really as part of
the final designs right because we're
just referencing these are just like
mood boards but when I look at the style
escapes do I know what to make from this
if I know what the brand applications
are intended to be can I look at the
elements here and know what I need to do
to translate that okay and in terms of
the element specific elements that I'm
looking for here are the things that
need to be on the
age the intended user the the user
profile that you've generated from your
strategy who is this intended for the
applications what does this need to be
this is need to be a logo this is need
to be icons for an app does this have to
be a website or merchandise does this
have to be painted as a mural on the
wall or tags for an event so
applications how many ways are you
showing how these how this can be used
next is typography typography is really
important with design work that we do
from messaging all the way to the logo
and all the other elements typography
how is it going to be used in do I get a
good sense of what that's going to look
like and then lastly color palette is
there a clear color palette that I know
if I'm going to start building a brand
around this style scape do I know what
colors to use okay so let's get into the
first submission this is from Noel
eyoung and she's doing her client is
Manco marketing so this was her brief
and I will just summarize this basically
she was a student of both our business
bootcamp and our style scapes course and
she partnered up with somebody from the
business boot camp to do his rebranding
from Manko marketing so what she did is
she looked to define his brand strategy
using core and then developed visual
identity around these keywords these
brand attributes a storied accomplished
aspirational and she based it off of the
existing logo that he had already and
started to build a visual design from
there so let's get into this let's
review this wow this is really nice I
like the bold red colors here typography
is really clean I love the dimension in
here and how dynamic some of these
elements are so fun let me pull up into
green so you can see I'm just trying to
absorb it and then trying to illuminate
my thoughts for you guys so you know
what I'm thinking when I'm looking
this I look at this and I get a good
sense of the colors right this bold red
that's used here and they're both in
flat and dimensional uses I also like
these overlays that we see right here
right like those are really nice I get a
good sense of again like how this might
be applied I could see if he's doing any
kind of design or reporting how that
some of the graphics might look there
and also actually I like this messaging
right here I believe Gregg menko who
wrote this I'm pretty sure this is his
positioning statement that he wrote you
were FinTech before that was even a word
so I know that his client bases working
with financial tech companies so he's
pitched down very narrow so that he can
talk directly to these companies who
work in finance and bridge the gap
between technology and finance and
getting that all up to speed right and
you can see some of the keywords right
here so this is very helpful for me so
that we know what all of the visuals
that we're looking at is based off of
it's based off of these keywords story
to accomplish in aspirational I'm not
quite sure what story means as a word
maybe I'm not that smart maybe my
vocabularies not that rich but maybe
somebody in the comments can let us know
but accomplish an aspiration I like it I
can understand to a degree okay so this
is our user here on the left side so I
can tell he's like an older probably
male character male client looks like he
has a phone so I know that he's kind of
always on the go he's always busy is
always working but he's smiling he's
happy he loves what he does so I get a
good sense of the user like who this is
intended for then as I look left to
right I can tell she made this clear
selection of what the color palette is
so it's gonna be mostly red she even had
this proportional bar here so it's gonna
be mostly red and then black will be the
secondary and then gray and white are
the second or tertiary colors here
so that's very helpful and then again I
could start to see how she might start
to use photography she has all black and
white photography that we see here and
here but the unique thing about this is
she has elements that break the frame
like this this is very cool you get to
see that now she's going to have fun
even though there's these nice kind of
like rigid boxes in kind of containers
for all the elements she's breaking that
with some of the photography they're
letting that bleed out you even look at
these clocks right here this is
fantastic I love how the shadows are
casting on there so it gives everything
a little bit more dimension so it's not
just this super flat graphic look so
that's what I see with the imagery there
and the typography it looks like she's
balancing both serif typography like we
see here with 2015 and even the body
copy here so it looks like it's being
used mostly for body copy and sometimes
decorative but it looks like the rest of
the typography might be more sans-serif
here but I look at these and I wonder if
we might tighten the typography a little
bit because I see a couple of different
elements at night I don't know that
they're all super tight yet again with
style escapes this is just a way to
start the conversation and we don't need
to end it and I'm just looking for if I
were to make something from this would I
know what I need to do and I think what
because I look at so many different
types ampuls here I feel like I wouldn't
know is this the heading over here with
the condensed type am I only using this
for decorative type here this 2015 and
then is body copy intended to be serif
or sans serif like we see here in here
right so I think if that would be one
critique that I have at least for the
typography right now that I think we
could start to define a little bit more
of the rules if we were to do another
iteration of this again my eye is still
moving left right and I love again the
use of the red going from things that
are really flat like these elements
right here and then getting into more
dimension
stuff right here and I could see how
this might apply to some stationary
elements like his business card and
again like these stationary elements
here but then I could also see how if he
were to have some kind of event this is
very cool because I'm not sure what
menko marketing aspires to do but I'd
imagine with some kind of marketing like
that that you might host events you
might invite some of your clients or
potential clients and other thought
leaders in the industry and gather them
all together so I could see that that's
an application for the use or it could
be that maybe that their office is
growing maybe they have multiple
employees and then this could be badges
for people who visit or who are
employees there so that's pretty cool in
terms of photography now I'm getting
over here to the bottom right and this
photo throws me off I know why it's in
there it's in there because it follows
the same color palette red and black but
the problem is I find that this keyboard
the style of this keyboard feels very
retro this feels like a like late 90s or
early 2000s keyboard so even though it
matches the color palette it throws me
off because everything else especially
if I think about thin tech I think it's
ultra modern ultra high-end and
something that it's probably more of
like a touchscreen right so these
elements like these phones and this
Lobby screen right here or sorry this
out like iMac right here these things
feel modern to me where I look at this
keyboard and it doesn't match so every
single element all the details matters
when I look at something like that it
really throws me off because I know if I
were to just if I were to just crudely
black this out and I'm doing this in
keynote so I don't have much tools like
look how much of a difference that makes
just removing that one element kind of
lifts up the whole image here and it
doesn't feel like it's brought down by
something that feels a little bit older
okay
all right
you don't see comments on there huh yeah
all right sorry I can't see the comments
here right now
hopefully you guys are hopefully you
guys are enjoying this what I'll do is
I'll probably do two more I'll take a
quick break and jump over to the
comments to see if there's any questions
that have popped up okay so let me move
on oh and this is super cool so from
that style escape Noella has actually
applied this to the design of the
landing page and I don't know if this is
Noel or Greg but you could see how all
the elements all the language from the
style scape has translated over to the
landing page here the home page here and
I can see this is again that same use of
black and white photography this is a
brilliant use of red right here with
with this balloon popping out that's
super cool and then now I could see how
the typography is defined so it looks
like for a heading we're using serif
fonts here and even for the body and it
looks like any buttons these are all the
condensed type here so it looks like
they have made some decisions
super cool all right let's move on to
the next person oh that's Oh
the lighting is all Jonah and and this
is all me man the Lighting's all Ricky
sorry Lighting's all Ricky credit where
credit's due
all right so let's get to the next
person
this next style scape is from Julius
silk and she did a project for TEDx I
assumed it was for Edmonds because I
read her brief but so I put it as TEDx
Edmonds here so that we know and if you
guys don't know TEDx is a locally run
chapter or series of the big TED
conference so you can run your own TEDx
conference if you follow their
guidelines so this one's for an Edmonds
TEDx so if we look at the style escapes
purpose really her brand applications
are to inspire the set design the event
logo the interactive activities social
media
host and fliers so very clear I'm glad
she highlighted that so I know what kind
of brand applications to look for or how
I might be looking at the images and
then if you see on the right here we
look at hoops sorry let me go back so if
we look at the these are the brand
attributes on the right side it's
inviting empowering and memorable all
right so let's go to the next slide all
right so this is her style scape for
TEDx right now I'm just observing I'm
just looking but this is a nice I gotta
say this is a nice pleasant break from
the previous one where the previous one
was all about tech and it's very bold
and very refined this one again is
inviting empowering memorable and I feel
like those keywords are great these guys
right here and I like even how they're
handwritten too or at least they feel
like they're handwritten because they I
could see that this carries all the way
over to all of the rest of the elements
why because it feels like everything is
hand done feels like everything is
grassroots and and and made and I'm
starting to get more clues because at
you know what I know who's going to
attend this event right here so it looks
like it's a younger female probably in
her 20s maybe in college or just out of
college she looks like she's an activist
just because I can kind of tell from her
shirt and that she cares a lot about
female empowerment just from that so
this adding to this and then seeing
these other words like you belong be a
nice human like I could I could already
get a sense of who attends this and what
those people might care about right so
very clear in terms of user profile
who's going to be attending this next
thing I look at color and I love this
eclectic color I'm personally always shy
of using so many colors I like to stick
to maybe two or three at the most but
when I see stuff like this and it's done
well I get really excited I feel like
one company that does this very well is
our friends over at Collins so if you
in the Dropbox rebrand it's so colorful
it's so fun and it's similar to this and
same with their work from vitaminwater
we had them on the we had Bryden Collins
on the show recently or last year rather
so go check that out if you haven't seen
it yet but anyways I digress I go back
to this style escape and again I'm just
pleasantly surprised with all the colors
that are being used here however I would
say to that point the color could be a
little bit more cohesive and here's what
I mean like I know that there is this
color palette that's set right here
honestly I think this typography and
there's just making this feel a little
bit crowded and busy because now this
typography is fighting with these
elements over here and fighting with
this and it gets very very busy right
here
so what I'd rather have this person do
is just remove the type there I don't
think that it's necessary but if this is
the color palette here I get that I can
see that here right that makes sense and
then maybe here even though that's a
little bit more muted actually this is
more in here but then I start to see
some things that are taking us off for
instance like where's this green coming
from how does that get used and then why
is there let me produce this why do we
see green here and then where is the
green over here right so these are
little things that I see where there's a
nice little bit of a carryover like
right there and then when we get over
here there's no more green so my eye
stops flowing so for me if we're gonna
decide to add this little pale
lime green into the mix then it I feel
like we have to see a little bit over
here somewhere by the hand or even up
here in this negative space right that
would look pretty nice and then I would
actually include that as a tertiary
color as part of the the color guide
here at the bottom and then where this
also gets inconsistent is right here
under go your own way this green again
it's very dark I'd rather I know this is
sounding like I'm getting so particular
but it these details matter these
details really matter when I'm a
designer I'm looking at
this and I'm trying to figure out well
what's the color palette what do I need
to design from here if I'm putting
together the brand guidelines from here
which is the right green to use and
these are the decisions that you have to
make eventually so I'd rather that
there'd be a little bit more clarity
there because it's nice I do like the
green and I just miss it within the
color palette that we've identified here
okay so that's color
the next thing I'm looking at is
typography so typography I could see
that it's quite eclectic and I kind of
like that actually
normally I feel like you know I we don't
really use too many different typefaces
sometimes we like to use two things that
have contrast from each other and
complement each other but because the
feeling of this is supposed to feel a
little bit more inviting and empowering
and I'm guessing a little bit more grass
roots is that it could feel hand done
and hand made so I think the best
examples of this are these keywords
right here this this Adam do mellow and
then something nice like those are
really really good where I start to get
thrown off a little bit is this and
again I know it's it's getting picky
here but I could tell that this wo it
feels like I don't know it doesn't feel
like the same qualities these other ones
doesn't have the same texture the way
that it's written is more I guess more
like cursive or handwritten in there and
were these other ones like they have a
certain quality I'm specifically talking
about this that had them do mellow in
something nice like those ones blend
together very well this wo on women up
just throws me off a little bit so if it
were me I would probably paint that out
or redraw that part just on that element
alone okay so next thing next thing is
imagery so I could tell that there is
some use of photography here but it even
feels like it's illustrated on I can't
really tell from here but it looks like
maybe this is a painting like a digital
painting but it's such a cool such a
cool look so it could tell that over and
over illustration is going to
be used throughout this language and
again maybe this is something that I
think we could tighten up a little bit
because it feels like the the language
between these three elements right here
feels a little bit different than this
and this so if we were to do another
round to tighten it up as a designer I'd
wonder which is the way to go which is
the language that we need to go so I
think we can make a decision right and
if I look at these things I feel like
the illustration can go one of two ways
one way is this line art that we see
here and here right so we could
consolidate everything to look like this
because this works very well with
elements like that right elements that
are handwritten they all have the same
qualities they go together well the
other direction that we can go for is
this kind of like semi rendered thing or
I should say highly rendered image
because I feel like it pairs well with
this right so I get and even with this
typography so from me if I were making
decisions I feel like we have to tighten
this up a little bit more and choose one
way or the other so that this could be
very very solid and somebody knows what
to do with it in terms of other graphic
elements here I could start to see this
cool use of these blobbies or folded
elements and what I'm talking about is
these little blobs over here on the left
side but then also these cool geometric
folded elements here where it's like a
dot pattern and then it's folded same
here this is a plus pattern and then
it's folded like that's super cool and I
could see that reiterated throughout
very very cool elements I wish there was
a little bit more over here on the right
side where you have another kind of like
repeating element and that will tie
together the whole style scape here
maybe even another element that goes
over here that so that now if we were to
do this you would have a really nice
flow from left to right so if you choose
to pick elements especially things that
are repeating like that and I feel like
you have to pepper it in in other areas
to balance out the composition okay so
now let's talk about the application
because I know the application for this
is
all about the stage right it supposed to
be the stage and all of the things that
would happen at an event and I'm not
seeing much stage elements actually so
these are all references for for mostly
posters and printed elements which is
good and I don't think that you need to
just show stage elements to introduce
what a stage can look like but if I'm
the stage designer do I know what to
make from this and it would be nice to
just have one element that would give me
an idea so for instance I'm looking at
this multifold panel right here is this
a backdrop for the speakers on stage
that could be very cool and this could
just be mocked up the way you would do
that is like maybe you would illustrate
or just comp in very quickly like a wood
stage right there so that you get a
sense of scale you might even put a tiny
person here so that you get a sense that
that's the backdrop right that could be
a cool way or even this element right
here I could see this is a very cool
stage space sorry like a stage element
where this could be off to the side so
this is very cool where you take
something that's very small which is
this little I forget what you call those
things but people had them in elementary
school but you can blow this up really
big and you can have all kinds of
messaging on the sides maybe all kinds
of empowering messages but this could be
blown up this could be really big this
could exist in the event space or even
this hand this hand would be dope as a
3d printed thing right it's something
that's really big in the space or maybe
paper mache or built out of something so
because this is meant for the stage I
just need a sense of how do these
elements work at something at that scale
because everything feels small right now
everything feels about poster size and I
have no idea of like what is the entire
stage that what would that look like the
only thing that might come close to that
are these balloons here but honestly I
feel like these balloons are the oddest
thing on the page if it were me I would
probably just remove those balloons all
together and just like knock those out
because I would just replace that I love
all these other colorful and eclectic
elements that thing just throws me off a
little bit okay anyways really good job
I think this is really
beautiful again I'm not one to get all
crazy colorful but I really love it when
I see stuff like this okay next person
let's go to Nathanael Nicodemus and he
has done work for a candy space
entertainment kse so let's take a look
at this let me blow this up for my old
eyes and he says the brand is Kenny
space entertainment developed a look and
feel the brand predict the future state
of the brand and wanted to create a
flexible creative direction for the
brand identity and the position in KSC
is the entertainment platform with a
transparent process model that empowers
creative youth with knowledge and
inspired generation to follow a life of
creativity in an era of decentralized
education so the positioning statement I
mean I know this is not what it's about
I think it needs a little bit of
cleanings a little clarity because
entertainment platform I'm not sure what
that means because you go to
entertainment platform but below it says
decentralized education
so is this an education platform is this
a place where people develop their
skills because that's what it leads me
to believe what the last sentence with
the decentralized education so I need a
little bit more I'm unsure what KSC is
just based off of the positioning
statement but that's not what we're
we're grading here but it is something
that's framing this so the brand
attributes to consider our futuristic
energetic and inspiring okay so let's go
to the next slide all right Wow
this man's after my heart I like this
stuff I really like this stuff and it
feels like I like to categorize this
stuff as retro future if I were to name
this I would call it retro future the
reason why is if you look at the quality
of the images here it kind of feels like
there's a tint on everything as if this
was printed on an old magazine cover and
it was just left out in the Sun and it
it aged a little bit so it has that
yellowish tint all the imagery has a
yellowish tint there's the white points
are never fully cool but it's kind of
imagining the future with things like
this I know one of his keywords is
futuristic energetic futuristic and
inspiring so this is pretty cool like
this like the idea of space travel right
that's a very retro future thing to
think about
even these I know this is a little bit
more of a modern DJ setup right here
because you have I think those are see
DJs and this is a laptop that's
controlling those that's definitely not
old-school so this is definitely more
contemporary but the way that it's
styled because of the lighting and the
tint on it it feels a lot more retro so
again I don't know if that was the
intent I personally like it and so when
I think of futuristic I think a better
word would be retro futuristic or retro
future because there's something so cool
where they're kind of on opposing sides
of the spectrum I really like the color
palette again I think this person has
chosen to do a good range of colors that
we could see here on the on the right
side the right side they have selected a
very eclectic color palette where it's
mostly red in proportion and then the
secondary colors are the black and then
the white over here and then these are
the tertiary colors which even I love
how this is organized it kind of feels
like old Tetris blocks or something that
are all piling up together
okay so color palette I think is really
good I think it could use a little bit
of tightening and why is that it's
because like you see there's a green
here and then there's a blue here
the problem is over here this is teal
this is in between the two same with
these right here these are teal so
there's a little bit of lack of cohesion
here
so what rather you do is like you sample
that color and probably replace that
green right there maybe even replace the
blue I don't even know if you need it
maybe this yeah yeah so there's a little
bit of an inconsistency there the only
time I see this blue is right here but
even that blue it's very rich
it's a little bit more saturated than
this one and it looks like the hue is a
little bit more blue and while this one
over here on the right side is a little
bit more green okay and I don't know how
good the compression is on YouTube but I
can clearly see the difference in these
colors let me know in the comments if
you guys can see the differences in the
hue saturation and values of those
colors and again I'm nitpicking I again
as a designer I think I would know what
to do with this but these would be
decisions that we have to make as we're
going forward and actually applying this
building to brand guidelines okay now
let's talk about some of the imagery
here so the imagery so I could see this
guy he looks like I don't know he looks
like he's very into very modern Street
where he has a little satchel right here
I don't know if that's what that's
called I have one of those things they
used to call them fanny packs I don't
think they call them that anymore
there's probably a cooler name right so
there's this guy
it looks like youthful urban and then
there's this concert over here going
back to the entertainment so I don't
know if this use if this guy is a
performer on stage again the brand
positioning wasn't super clear to me but
my assumption is that this is KS e is an
some kind of entertainment company that
helps nurture and facilitate young
aspiring artists to perform so if that's
the case then a lot of this makes sense
like this guy this guy over here is
singing to that audience over there in
terms of the graphics like I love this
image here love these these are very
very abstract but man these are pretty
cool this feel like what you might see
on Spotify or SoundCloud when you're
looking
aspiring artists so this feels very much
in the norm of that there's a lot of
aspiring artists that I follow music
artists that I follow where they have a
lot of retro graphics that look like
this so I could see how things are
cohesive in that sense and luckily I'm
not too old to be out of touch with all
of this stuff in terms of iconography I
can see that there's some elements here
here and here
and I feel like maybe this thing on the
right this yellow tree looking thing
kind of works the other ones throw me
off a little bit I don't know how these
all fit in together for some reason this
yellow tree thing feels like almost like
something that you would see from an
outdoor brand where this I'm not sure
what this shape is right here next to
this characters face it kind of feels
like some retro sports graphic right
this could be on a jacket on the side of
a windbreaker jacket or something and
then this stuff down here definitely
feels retro you feel like if you flip
open an old icon book from the 70s it's
definitely from that style so maybe from
the time era these things all match but
for whatever reason I'm not quite sure
how I might use them yet because maybe
in this application this makes sense for
a social graphic or a poster but these
guys right here I have no idea what the
heck I'm going to do with them so if
these are meant to be let's say if there
was an app for the phone I would like to
see this in that context so I know what
it's for or if this is for our website
or something like that I'd like to see
what that's for so that I get a sense
because it feels like there's no
relationship to those things to anything
else on the page okay so I know his big
goal was to have something pretty
versatile I think there is definitely
some versatility here I think there's a
couple things that we can tighten up
between the colors and then the
iconography the graphics and everything
else I'm pretty okay with I'm okay with
the images being as eclectic as they are
I would say that this actually now that
I'm looking at it this element here it
looks like
this is a website landing page it
doesn't feel like it has the same tone
as this right here it feels like this
gets very white so this is a small tweak
but what I would do is I would just take
the whites in there and tint those a
little bit yellow lower the value just a
touch and I'm missing some of these cool
retro graphics right here these retro
elements so if all of a sudden let me
undo this so if I were to take that this
thing you might repeat that cool grid
pattern over here right like you might
do something like that or you might take
this a textured element that you have
from this photo right here and have that
bleedin and feel like a cool overlay
just so it feels a little bit more like
the language you're establishing here
because right now this feels a little
disconnected from everything else okay
okay so I think that's it for KSEE
before I move on let's go check the
comments so Jaden you can stay on me I'm
gonna go just jump into YouTube real
quick and check the comments oh that's
that's a great question this does okay
great
that's a great question so the
difference between a mood board and a
stylus Cape is mostly in terms of how
you present it with mood boards or style
tiles as some people call it you would
just gather a bunch of elements you put
them together and you good mood boards
will be very tight and it will help
describe something the difference with a
style escapes because of this ultra wide
format we're trying to imagine a couple
of things we're trying to have an
empathy Grapher who the user is and what
they care about
next we're trying to show the elements
how are all of these graphics how are
all the elements how do they matter to
the final output the applications so
we're trying to give a sense of if it's
going to be online what does the website
look like what does the app look like if
this is meant to be an event space what
does the environment to look
and and just do a little bit of tweaking
outside of the curation of the work so
mood boards traditionally again you you
grab a bunch of images and you put them
together and you talk about it with your
clients which style escapes you actually
do a little bit more work where you're
curating the work you're color
correcting it you're making adjustments
you're probably painting a little bit in
here and they're just just enough work
not a whole lot because you don't want
to invest a whole lot of time creating
something just something where it feels
really tight and cohesive so that both
you and your client know what the visual
direction is going to be because I've
done both in the past I've done mood
boards and me and my client will be
nodding yes we know what this means and
then we start making it and then all of
a sudden there's all these undefined
things are we using this blue or are we
using this blue is it more teal is it
more purple well what about the
typography are we using sans-serif are
we using this condensed type what are
the rules here these are all the
questions that get opened up and left
open with mood boards and then allow for
interpretation down the line and then
misalignment between you and your client
where style escapes kind of closes that
gap and gets you guys all aboard is that
because you've done the work of curating
and really tightening up what's on the
page then you have a way of presenting
something that is gonna be a lot more
aligned with what the final vision might
look like and in our course if you take
it Chris talks about how you present
this stuff it's not just about well
here's the thing because it mostly
speaks for itself but there's a way of
presenting this stuff that you might
have somebody read as you can tell the
way that I'm evaluating this thing is
more of from the perspective of a
designer as a creative director I'm
trying to understand the elements and
where it goes
clients will review it and be presented
in the same way but they also need to be
guided they need to be guided to know
what they're looking at and in what they
might respond to and it's a back and
forth again this is a discussion tool
where you present it you have a
discussion you you lead a little bit and
then you let them go see where their
mind wanders and you help them connect
the dots okay
it's the technical question yes so so do
we only use photos we know you don't
have to again what we're trying to do is
we're trying to define so let me restate
the questions in case you didn't hear it
so the question is do you only use
photos that are within the color palette
that you've defined no you don't have to
it's nice again for me personally I like
keeping very tight color palettes but as
we seen in some of the examples you can
use very eclectic colors and those can
go together and you could have different
brand colors that work with full-color
photos right there's plenty of examples
out there and advertising where you'll
see there's a brand color applied for
instance like Xbox because I'm familiar
with it their color is green so they
have green do they only use green photos
no they use the native artwork that
comes from all the different publishers
that send them games but there's a
cohesion bits because they all use that
green bar in the same kind of graphic
elements so you don't have to use photos
that are limited to the color palette
that you've chosen they just need to
work together right the next evolution
of the style scape is you start building
so as we looked in some of the creative
briefs here is whatever that brand
application is so if we go back to the
TEDx example we know that this is
supposed to influence the stage design
and some of the event material so what
you might do from there is you look at
those elements and then you see how
might I translate that like again I was
looking at that bifold element or that
little little puzzle thing that you flip
open like how can I turn that into a
stage element what what can what
iteration of that can I can I do so now
I'm looking at the particular elements
on the stage sorry on the style scape
and I'm trying to interpret that for the
actual use case and I'm looking at the
color palette now I know how to transfer
these things over if we were to go back
to let me go back to the building a
brand stuff we did for Hamilton I will
show you exactly where how these things
translate
so for hamiltonfamily brewery you can
see above we took all of these elements
that we found we color corrected them we
curated the right elements cuz we still
didn't use everything this is just a
place to start off from but you can see
below how our designers interpreted that
with this blue can up here it wasn't
originally blue I think it was steel but
we flipped all this stuff just to get
much closer I'll show you an example
let me draw on this so you know what I'm
talking about I'm talking about this can
right here this was a found element and
we augmented it pretty significantly
just to get it to get to that point so
everything's using the same blue you can
see there's a lot of similar elements
right here you can see how this will
these right here were references for the
logos we like these circular elements
and you can see how that turned into the
logo right here so basically again this
is just a starting point but when the
clients saw all of these elements like
the colors and the cans they already
knew we were where we were heading
because they agreed on the style scape
here we were all aligned on the
direction before we headed forward okay
cool so thank you for bringing up those
questions what I'd like to do now Jaden
is I'll get back and then I will review
the next couple of ones and then we can
go back to questions so if you guys have
follow-up questions and these are great
questions by the way thank you so much
for asking them it's really making me
think luckily I'm not sweating here
let's go to the next one so the next
I'll escape submitted by students Angelo
Pascucci I hope I said that right and
this is for Casa Millan i T so it is
Casa Millan Casa Millan and the client
request is they needed logo design and
I'm thinking this is probably going to
bleed out to their brand identity custom
Elan is a online news site and
e-commerce for the football team
AC Milan they care about trust
reliability and staying true to their
audacious statement of the football team
and this is their user Antonio 20 32 to
40 year old factory
work or father of two so this is a great
user profile I can kind of sense who he
is he's living that dead life but he
gets his excitement by watching football
right so the brand attributes that we're
looking at our reliable simple bold and
the style scape name is blazing that's
one tip that we haven't really talked a
lot about but for us we like to give our
style scapes names so when we presented
to the Hamiltons we gave each of them a
name so that helped frame before they
even saw in the image what they might be
looking at so the one that you saw we
call that merit badge because it had a
bunch of elements that look like merit
badges that you would get in Boy Scouts
or Girl Scouts so it gave them a little
sense of oh this is about adventure this
is about learning and that's what that
client was about so this person called
it blazing so when I'm flip to the next
page I'm assuming that it's going to be
pretty bold right and that it's gonna be
a little audacious like you said right
here but he also uses these other two
words reliable and simple which i think
is a choice to put with blazing but
we'll see how it all comes together
because if this is their fan I know they
would appreciate something wild okay
alright so this is the style scape
cozumel an IT and this is how it changed
attend Abul simplest or dito oh he
probably this is probably an Italian and
it was translated for me oh that's
probably also why maybe the words were
not quite the most descriptive when I
translated over to English I'm not sure
I'm making assumptions there but I can
tell from this character right here he's
very wild he is he's definitely a
football fan I can see how some of this
might permeate through some of the rest
of the elements here so we know that the
use case is going to be for a logo again
eventually probably a full brand
identity so again I get a good sense of
the person here
I love again these bold red and white
even in the seats this is super cool I'm
sure if we were to zoom up this white
probably makes up the shape of the logo
if we are looking from across the way so
that's very cool when I think of bold
this is really nice I love this
typography example here where the type
is so big it's so loud it's condensed
it's getting cut off the page like to me
that says bold that says loud that says
audacious it kind of matches this guy's
almost like he's yelling all right can
you guys see that
feels like he's yelling but it also
feels like this typography is is yelling
- so he's yelling here
this feels like it's yelling and I like
how this is replicated here where you
have these typography elements that are
getting cut off or getting repeated like
Olleh Olleh Olleh right there that's
very nice where I feel like this starts
to fall apart is when I see the other
typography so if I'm looking at this
free culture here and then I'm looking
at this number 4 I feel like this is a
missed opportunity also with this big
data summit this thing throws me off I
wish all the elements the typography on
the page all look like this little set
of boxes right here where things are cut
off they feel like they're pushing to
the edge so if this number 4 if I were
to make an adjustment to that thing I
would use a very condensed font and then
have that go all the way over there
right and just have that feel like it's
a little bit more bold really condensed
because like you could feel that like it
feels loud it feels audacious and then
you could still have the like the micro
type right there like to me that would
feel a lot more cohesive with the other
typography elements and then for this
big data summit I think the same thing
this this serif font that was chosen
here throws me off because it starts to
feel like this condensed font and maybe
even these things that are a little bit
more playful like they have a lot of
character to them and then I look at
this big data summit and it feels pretty
boring and it feels like data I feels
like a tech company so this typography
element throws me off so for me and
again this is the difference between
mood board
and style escapes is with style escapes
you would take these iterations you
would take the references that you find
and then just make slight alterations to
it so that people will understand what
the end results going to look like a
designer who has to work with this after
knows what they have to do with it so I
would change this big data summit into
that big condensed font and maybe let
that summit bleed off the page because
you'll still be able to read it if that
thing gets cut off there same with the
type here blazing score from Ronaldo and
then what I would like to see is an
example of body copy and I don't know if
this is the example of body copy right
here it doesn't feel like it it doesn't
feel like it's as exciting as this thing
and maybe that's okay maybe it needs to
be a little bit more simple to pair with
that but for some reason this typeface
right here doesn't feel like it pairs
with this free culture typeface so
typography I have a lot of have a lot of
feedback on this that I think could
tighten it up even this Milan right here
si mi la this is a geometric typeface
same with this cost them alone it looks
kind of like Gotham but then is that the
same font that we're using here and here
like it hmm yeah I'm confused I guess
that's what I'm getting I think we just
need to make some decisions so if we
were to do another round of this I would
just tighten up the decisions we're
making it for typography so I know what
we as a designer as a team would have to
do with this okay now we know that it's
intended for a logo the thing is I don't
see many logos outside of these two and
maybe that's the look of the logo and I
like that but if this is the intent of
the logo I'd probably make these bigger
in the frame so while you have
everything in here this is an issue for
me right now it feels like all of these
elements that you've chosen to put they
all feel the same exact size and in this
sense size and proportion matters to the
overall look so when we're looking at it
this wide if you want something to be
super important like the logos here I
will just take that logo and just take
up the whole thing right there right I
would take that our element and then
just do that right there
so you get a sense and then what you
could probably do is have a few more
graphic elements down here that could
serve as just secondary and tertiary
examples of what other logos in that
style where this is a mono line logo
what that looks like right so I'd rather
see a little bit more of that if that is
the final output then you can still keep
these nice examples of the free culture
and this type stuff I would keep that up
here and even what it looks like in the
arena this business card very boring I
probably would X that out like that
thing isn't that great I like the
backside right because it's a cool mono
line logo that you're trying to go for
this thing right here but this thing is
boring so that would be another element
if you decide to keep that I would
augment the typography on there to feel
more like what's going on okay I think
that's it for me I'd like to move on so
that everybody gets a chance so next one
is from Dave cray you've filled great
volt and I'm sorry if I butchered your
name you're gonna have to next time just
send us an audio file saying your name
so that I could get the pronunciation
right so this is for dotnet that's the
client that he's making this for so
about the style scape the style scape is
for a project we did for for dotnet
simply put in IT staffing company for
dotnet developers our job was to help
them sharpen their positioning and a
simple rebranding they didn't want to
lose their legacy because of the long
term running family company but they
also knew that they had to make steps to
become a stronger brand after the
discovery session they found out the
focus of the brand should be that they
are experts in their field trustworthy
partner and wanted to show a bit more
guts not too formal okay so these are
keys I think I already understand so
this is their demographic they're about
30 to 40 their younger managers right so
they're not like sniffing old they're
older but they kind of like me right
like not not out of touch they're still
understand technology but they're not
too formal and I got a bit of gut so
that makes me feel like
they're okay to be a little bit more
edgy let's go to the next let's look at
the style escapes okay so this is for
for.net so first of all the color
palette very familiar I wonder why it
feels like our colors which I like
however I will say there's an issue here
and maybe this is just the color
conversion but can you guys see this
before I even say it Jaden can you see
it the color you see what's wrong with
the color is it okay alright maybe
people online know what's wrong with the
color
there's inconsistencies here yeah oh
look
Jonah knows what he's talking about so
let's look at this this blue right here
is a very rich blue and then if you look
at the blue selected here what's wrong
there's more red in there there's more
red in that blue and then if you look at
this blue right here there's more green
in that blue and then there's more red
in this blue and then so on and so forth
so we can pick this apart again
I am nitpicking at this point I just
feel like as a designer when we go from
here if I'm sampling this blue that's
fine I'll go with that
but honestly like my favorite blue on
this whole page is this guy right here
this set of colors is so beautiful I
like a little bit more green in there I
like I like this instead of things that
have too much red in it because when I
see a blue like that on the left side
this guy right here
it's like just make it purple and I'd
rather just see a nice rich purple this
feels like it's in between and I hate it
when blue falls in that in-between stage
but that's just me that's just personal
preference there's no science behind
that that's just me and then what I like
so I see a couple different blues I
think it's the first thing we didn't
tighten up let's see next thing let's
get into the typography so I know this
is a light refresh on the brand identity
for for.net so they're they're looking
at all kinds of application
so so I'm seeing typography and all
kinds of spaces which is represented in
their photos so this is I'm guessing
their office this is if they were to
throw an event same here this is
probably an event material and then if
they were to have what he called it if
they were to have a billboard somewhere
so it's interesting I like the context
of all these spaces I could see how they
bleed out I can get a good example like
this is probably inside the hallway of
their office and then what typography
will look like on their website however
I feel like the typography I'm gonna say
it over and over again we need to define
the rules because I see many different
typefaces here I see this typeface is a
spaced out geometric type I like that
it's kind of similar to this this works
well and then you have this condensed
weight which could be fine if we define
the rules but then you have something a
little bit more traditional this one
looks like Helvetica
and then I'm not sure what typeface this
one is this is actually from blind but I
don't even know what tie face we chose
for that because I didn't work on that
project
so I feel like the rules need to be
defined a little bit more personally I
really like these samples right here it
feels like it works there's a nice
variation of heavy and big versus
something that's really tiny which is
the body copy there I even loved this
element right here it says empower and
it's underlined and I'm missing that
from everywhere else so this is a cool
element where it feels like a little bit
hand done as if they put their final
touch on it they care about the craft of
the work that they do which is to train
mighty people but I don't see that motif
repeated anywhere else so if that's
something that you or your client
latched onto if we were to do another
iteration of this maybe on the hello
welcome you would underline that or it's
like people don't quit jobs they leave
bad managers then you would do another
underline there or it could be in the
space architectural graphics you could
have a cool black band over here
underneath
I'm drawing on the backlight you could
repeat these elements you can have these
cool little things come into frame to
help reinforce the idea you can even use
this as graphic element so maybe there's
this cool graphic underlying element
that's coming out from behind the
character here and this just helps drive
your eye to places again I'm just
dreaming up things I'm not sure I wasn't
in the room with you and your client but
I latched on to that thing as if I were
your client and I would like to see more
of those elements populated throughout
okay
now let's talk about some of the photos
so I think the photos are all a well
done there nicely white balance all of
this tog Rafi is very clean and minimal
there's a few missed opportunities
though I'm thinking right here this
space this image takes up a lot of space
and I don't know if this was an intent
to show this is what photography looks
like or if this is an example of what
their office would look like because I
see it as cool let's see this cool
yellow wire for their lamp it's like
okay I get it it kind of connects to
this but why not mock something up on
this wall why can't we see the big four
from their brand up there you know some
cool typography on there I think that's
just a missed moment there that would be
very cool where it will start to get
your client dreaming like where else can
our logo exist where else can our
branding exist how do we brand our space
you could even look at some of the
graphic elements that you're starting to
introduce here like these are bands that
we see right there
right here and you could just do a big
color-block on that wall and that would
be so sick I'd love to work in a space
where there's a whole like you know
color block like that and then the rest
is just the raw concrete that could be
super sick and then you could also take
these wires and you could paint all the
wires so it's like blue blue black and
then that yellow so you can have fun
moments like that where by doing these
what are you doing you're allowing to
see the work that you're doing for your
clients to be much bigger and much
broader we've been brought on sometimes
to just do a website and then when we
present the style escapes the clients
like whoa well that's a cool idea we
never thought of that what a few
designer into
your space for this building which we've
done before which is crazy and that's
another power of style escapes that
helps you and your client dream up
something much bigger than what you guys
originally thought of so we love doing
this in terms of looking for other
applications where else this applies
again we were talking about the
environment but this is cool right here
so there are these kind of like room
dividers that you're hanging up really
tall and they slide in and out but I
love that you color treated them to be
blue so it looks like the the branding
there and even this I'm not sure where
the storage containers would come in but
maybe the idea is that this is one of
their offices I don't know are they that
bold but I mean this is cool because you
have all these colors that are imagined
there and then one thing that throws me
off is this photo right here this photo
right here feels a little bit it looks
like a showroom floor but it's these
lights these detailed lights up here and
the reason why I have an issue with it
is everything feels so refined it's
about natural raw materials with natural
white balance light bleeding in right
then you have this thing where it's this
is fluorescent lighting fluorescent
lighting and that just throws off the
feeling of any space so if for my
preference I would say that we just
remove this because this doesn't give me
a good sense of the overall feeling of
everything also the photography and what
the space could be again I'm nitpicking
this is just if I were your creative
director or if we were to do another
iteration on this these are the things
that I would like to tighten up okay I'm
done there's there any other questions
or feedback that we can address right
now okay well the question is how does a
style scape work with an existing logo
that a client wants to keep this is one
example of it so if we cut back to my
screen for.net that thing is on the left
side there
this designer decided to they had to
keep the logo so what are they looking
at they're looking at the color that
they have there in their logo and
they're permeating that throughout
they're looking at the geometric
elements like the lines of the princess
like if we're looking at the shape you
see the whole the the monoline width of
all of the typography where else is that
repeated right here doo-doo-doo-doo so
they're taking this information and
they're looking at how they're going to
bleed that out and right here this
yellow bar right here so again I think
there's more that could be done but I
feel like this logo could probably live
pretty comfortably with typography like
this you see how there's a connection
between those two elements so this
designer is really thinking about that
I'd probably lose the all-caps that's
down here at the bottom maybe lose the
all-caps right here because there's
something about this title case example
that feels like it's already connecting
with the brand so just because you're
doing a style escape to imagine part of
the assignment that you are being hired
to do doesn't mean that you have to
throw out everything that the client has
built right because people have legacies
in their brand and people will recognize
if you change it and alter it way too
much for us a few years ago we worked
with enemy Expo and they had a logo that
they've been using for the past 19 years
or so we suggested that we do a little
refresh but all we did is we just
corrected the typefaces the the letter
forms in there a little bit more we
fixed a few weird issues that it had and
it still looked essentially the same and
we had a rollout period over a year
where you would see a mix of the old
logo and the new logo so they don't have
to reprint everything all at once and
then slowly one at a time as they print
new elements new banners new merch they
would start using the new logo and it
was this soft to transition out and
nobody even recognized that we had
changed the logo there another question
where does the scripts come into the
design process so after you have your
initial discovery meeting with your
clients and you understand what it is
the strategy is moving forward you get
your creative
brief this is before you do any visual
design so before you spend weeks and
weeks and weeks designing a logo
designing the website because it could
take a lot of time and get take a lot of
resources you would do a style scape in
a day in a few hours like these things
you could you could do very very quickly
the more you do it the faster you get at
it because you start developing your
your image banks you start to understand
how these things flow and how they work
and you just get faster and faster I
remember the first couple of times we
did this it took a couple days maybe
four or five days and eventually got
down to I can do one in a day right so
yeah you use this early on to bridge
that gap between what you and your
client have talked about in the
discovery session or what you got in
their brief and then you connect that to
the bridge of before you do the visual
design because once you do the visual
design things get expensive and if you
change direction there you lose money
you get resentful and then you start to
hate the job
Dallas capes is an easy way because it's
not really your work you're just
curating stuff and you're just trying to
get the conversation headed in the right
direction and usually present three
style escapes which is what we teach in
the course like how to show variation
between the style escapes right now
we're only looking at one at a time
maybe these are the ones that the
clients had selected but we like to show
them difference why is that well it's
because maybe the middle option is your
favorite one but you still have to show
them two other options for contrast so
that they know that that is the best
choice otherwise if you only show client
one example they will still think what
else is out there so that's that's where
you would use this in in lieu of
presenting original design cause if
you're presenting original design are
you going to make three unique designs
and then have them come back and they
don't really like any of them and
because they weren't what they imagined
and you already spent weeks on that this
is where style escapes come in
the question is has this gone through a
lot of testing I don't know what testing
means like I guess if you could clarify
the question what do you mean by testing
do we look at this internally and do we
check and vet it out and refine yes we
do that when we get it to client it's a
discussion so just because we have three
style escapes we look at them and we
evaluate together we discuss and we
might say you know we like mostly
Direction a but we like these two or
three elements from Direction B and what
we'll do is we'll just tighten it up
we'll do another round and then bring
those together and then we're all set
and we're good to go so that everybody
has buy-in and alignment so I'm assuming
that's what you were asking all right
empathy map well that's directly in the
course so if you take the course you'll
be able to learn how Chris does that
there but an empathy map is you're just
trying to get the user that we've
generated here like if you cut to my
screen so there's this user that we see
on the left side and you're just trying
to imagine a day in his life his POV
what are the things he cares about so it
this is already actually well curated
because we identified that this user is
30 to 40 years old he's a little bit
more young and they're a little bit more
hip a little bit more edgy so you could
tell he's wearing a blue suit instead of
a normal black and gray suit and it's
not even Navy it's like this cool teal
ish suit not not too vibrant and what's
cool he's showing a little bit of bling
he's got his gold watch here he's not
wearing a tie so you start to think
about who is this character what what
does he want to do this guy probably
looks like he enjoys watching sports he
has a lot of buddies and he probably
likes to hang out and do activities he
looks relatively fit so I'm just making
all these assumptions but an empathy map
would show these in images and this is
something that you would show too
that you potentially could show to your
client or you just do this as an
exercise beforehand as you're trying to
define the user profile that you're
designing for right gotcha
so the question is if there's feedback
on the style scape what do you do do you
move forward or do you continue with the
style scape and it really depends if you
have the luxury of time if you have it
in your budget what I would do I think
it's worth it to just refine it no
matter what so if the if the feeling in
the room this is 70% there but I don't
like this element in this element just
swap them out it's gonna save you a lot
of headache and get confirmation again
because the more you get alignment early
on the less time you're gonna spend on
the back end redoing work because
something was not defined so to me it's
always worth it
especially if you have the luxury of
time so we always try to do up to three
rounds of revisions for our clients but
we use that language very specifically
we're not saying you have three rounds
of revisions we say we can use up to
three rounds of our visions until we get
it right so that if we knock it out of
the park the first time and we know that
we can move forward from here like
everything is defined we're all clear
then we're not gonna make any more
tweaks even if one element is off we
know what to do with that because
everything else is clear and we might
document that in an email or something
after it's like okay we all agreed that
Direction a is the way to go every bit
of these style escapes except for the
image of the business card right here in
the middle we'll make sure that we avoid
any elements that have that feel like
the typography is this boring right and
then we would just define that and if
everybody says yes yes yes again it's a
communication tool it just helps us
bridge the gap and then we'll move
forward with executing the brand
identity there so from there we'll start
developing what the logo looks like the
color palette which is pretty much
defined here and we'll start looking at
brand applications whatever the job
calls for
I think the last question is how the
messaging come into play in size or okay
so the question is how does messaging
come into style escapes how does it play
ideally it would be very nice if you
have a little one-liner there or a short
paragraph that eloquently describes the
brand so in Discovery a lot of the times
we like to work out messaging with our
clients we like to come up with a either
internal or external positioning
statement with them that's what we do in
part of our discovery so we come up with
some messaging which is the other half
of communication design right there's
the visuals and then there's the text
that partners with it or what's being
said as partner with it so it's nice to
have that represented on your style
scape but it's not always necessary so
we've done projects where we're not
hired to do the messaging necessarily so
we might just show the client's logo and
then the keywords that describe it that
we all decided together these are the
brand attributes that we focused on for
this thal escape so that still helps
curate and frame what it is that we're
looking at through these brand
attributes but it's not as defined as
something like a messaging which is very
nice to have if you have it okay I think
that's pretty much it we are rounding
out the hour here so let's just get back
to my slide deck here we are at the end
and I really hope you guys enjoyed this
critique I have a lot of fun doing this
I love seeing the student work from our
course it's just because it's so
beautiful you guys have even though I
have a lot of feedback really all of
these ones that I chose were beautiful
they're gorgeous and I'm just nitpicking
at this point so that you all can see
these and all learn from this so your
question might be now how do you get
critiqued on feedback Fridays because we
want to be doing this more and more
often well that's quite simple if you
sign up for one of our courses Academy
dot the futurecom right now we're going
to be focusing on different design
courses that we teach so we teach
typography lettering and there's the
style scapes course there's my style
frames course
as well as many other things on there
and right now we're going to just focus
on giving design critiques on this
channel if you purchase our course so by
purchasing the course you get all the
course materials all the video lessons
and then you get invited to an alumni
slack group where we put postings there
for how to submit and then hopefully we
can get the cadence of doing this every
other Friday twice a month or maybe even
every week if we get really good if we
can get more people cycled in here but
for now this is just an experiment so I
really like to know from you guys if you
guys have feedback for a feedback
Fridays if you found something
insightful leave us a timestamp comment
below because this helps me know and
reflect back I could look at the tape
and then see what is it that you guys
enjoyed what did you find insightful
because we can go deeper on those things
and if you had more follow-up questions
that I didn't get to answer on today's
livestream again leave me a question
below a timestamp really helps so I know
what it's related to and we are at the
end here thank you so much for joining
us I am Matthew encina if you want more
content we're going to be linking a
couple of videos here on the end screens
and we'll also put a little link to the
rest of our content because some of you
guys don't realize that we have the
future Channel we have the future
Academy Channel which we're on we have
audio podcasts on pretty much every
platform
we're on Facebook Instagram Twitter
we're everywhere and we have tons of
blog posts out there so if you want to
learn more about design education and
business make sure you check it out and
I'll leave the links here well that's it
for us today guys hope you guys have a
wonderful weekend and we will see you
guys in the future